[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo ihr Lieben ein neuer Tag und ein
neuer Fall hier bei Tatort Deutschland
ich bin Toni Heyer und zum Glück hilft
mir wieder mein lieber Mirko Kasimir
dabei heute den Überblick zu behalten
hallo Mirko hallo liebe Toni ja du hast
recht ich glaube auch dass wir uns heute
sehr gut sortieren müssen denn unsere
Hauptperson hatte alles andere als einen
geradlinigen Lebenslauf und wir müssen
seit längerem mal wieder eine Warnung
aussprechen denn in diesem Fall gibt es
einige sehr drastische Details also wer
in dieser Hinsicht empfindlich ist der
sollte diese Ausgabe des Podcasts besser
nicht hören okay ihr seid gewarnt wir
erzählen euch heute von der schwarzen
Dahlie aber das ist eigentlich nur ihr
Spitzname den Elisabeth short erst nach
ihrem Tod bekam zu Lebzeiten nannten die
meisten Sie Betty
wir fangen heute mal mit dem Ende an und
bringen die grausigen Details schnell
hinter uns okay
Los Angeles am Morgen des 15 Januar 1947
bei der Polizei geht ein Notruf ein eine
Spaziergängerin hat gegen 10 Uhr 30 eine
Frauenleiche im Gras gefunden
sie liegt neben dem Bürgersteig auf der
westlichen Seite der Norden Avenue
zwischen der kolosseumstreet und der 39
West im Stadtteil America Park kurz zur
Einordnung wir befinden uns in etwa 15
Autominuten südwestlich entfernt vom
Zentrum der Stadt Hollywood liegt etwa
20 Minuten Richtung Norden die Reporter
der wichtigsten Zeitungen haben den
Polizeifunk mitgehört und sorgen für
einen Riesenwirbel am Fundort also da
wimmelt es nur so von Fotografen bei der
Leiche bzw den Körperteilen handelt es
sich um eine junge Frau mit schwarz
gefärbten Haaren
sie ist dort auf bizarre Weise
regelrecht inszeniert worden
die nackte Leiche ist an der Hüfte in
zwei Teile geteilt worden
einige Zentimeter abgerückt liegt ihr
Unterleib mit gespreizten Beinen ihre
Brüste wurden teilweise abgeschnitten
das Gesicht ist jeweils von den
Mundwinkeln an so zu den Ohren
aufgeschlitzt worden dass es ein
grausiges Lächeln zeigt die Polizisten
und Reporter sind schockiert kein
einziges der schrecklichen Fotos ist je
irgendwo veröffentlicht worden eine
wunderschöne Frau bestialisch ermordet
die Öffentlichkeit ist elektrisiert und
angelehnt an den damaligen Kinohit die
blaue Dahlie bekommt die tote von der
Presse jetzt den Spitznamen schwarze
Dahlie aber nicht nur die zur
Schaustellung der Leiche ist rätselhaft
auch die Umstände denn offenbar wurden
die Körperteile im Wasser gelagert oder
sogar eigens gewaschen am Tatort findet
sich keinerlei Blut schnell wird
gemutmaßt Meter müsste Arzt sein
vielleicht gar Chirurg das würde die
fachmännischen Schnitte erklären und
besonders die glatte Zerteilung von
Ober- und Unterkörper also wer hat das
getan und wer war diese Frau Elisabeth
short genannt betty ist die mittlere von
fünf Schwestern sie wird am 29 juli 1924
in Boston geboren ihr Vater Clio Alvin
short verdient sein Geld mit dem Bau von
minigolfplätzen damit geht er aber in
der Wirtschaftskrise 1929 pleite und
verschwindet spurlos seine Frau Fibi may
geht davon aus dass er Selbstmord
begangen hat okay das fängt jetzt alles
schon mal ziemlich kompliziert an also
wir finden in den lebenslaufen jetzt
eine alleinerziehende Fibi die sich und
ihre fünf Töchter mit Jobs als
Buchhalterin und mit Sozialhilfe über
Wasser hält Elisabeth short gilt als
hübsches beliebtes Mädchen mit
mittelmäßigen Schulnoten
später als junge Erwachsene hat sie
gesundheitliche Probleme Betty leidet an
Asthma und hat depressive Schübe sie
geht wegen des Klimas nach Florida und
Job dort in einem Strandhotel nach der
Highschool arbeitet sie zeitweise als
Model in Bettys Leben geht es drunter
und drüber erstmal taucht im Jahr 1942
ihr Tod geglaubter Vater wieder auf er
schreibt seiner Frau Fibi einen
versöhnungsbrief die will aber jetzt
nichts mehr von ihm wissen aber Betty
schreibt ihm und zieht sogar zu ihrem
Dad nach Los Angeles dort hat sie eine
Affäre mit einem Soldaten namens Chuck
aber schon bald überwirft sie sich mit
ihrem Vater weil der ständig trinkt und
pleite ist
sie nimmt einen Job an auf einer Airbase
nördlich von La tja und so langsam wird
klar das Betty mit ihrem Aussehen
richtig Geld verdienen kann sie will
Schauspielerin werden schafft es aber
leider nur zum Partygirl oder wie man
damals sagt zur Hostess oder zum
animiermädchen es fängt vielleicht damit
an dass sie in der Kaserne zum cutie of
the Week gewählt wird also zur süßesten
Frau der Woche sie wird in dieser Zeit
zum ersten Mal aktenkundig als Betty am
23 September 1943 ohne erwachsene
Begleitung Alkohol konsumiert die
Polizei kassiert sie ein und nimmt ihre
Fingerabdrücke
daraufhin zieht sie für eine Weile
wieder zu ihrer Familie nördlich von
Borsten ihr Leben spielt sich jetzt
jahrelang abwechselnd im Großraum Los
Angeles oder in Florida ab in l.a hofft
sie weiter auf eine Filmkarriere sie
glaubt als Hostess in der legendären
Hollywood kennt ihn und in dieser Zeit
lernt auch einige Schauspieler kennen
angeblich sogar den legendären Orson
Welles und sie hat wohl eine Affäre mit
einem Piloten namens Joseph Viking und
auch die nächste Liebschaft geht Betty
mit einem Piloten ein der heißt Matthew
Gordon und diesmal soll es etwas ernster
werden die beiden lernen sich in Florida
kennen und wollen nach dem Krieg
heiraten behauptet Betty zumindest
später aber es kommt mal wieder anders
kurz nach dem Krieg erfährt Betty das
Matthew in Indien mit dem Flugzeug
abgestürzt und gestorben ist sie
verlangt als angeblich Verlobte Geld von
dessen Familie aber damit blitzt Sie ab
jetzt geht es für sie nach Chicago dort
trifft sie zufällig ihren vorigen Freund
fickling wieder die beiden kommen erneut
zusammen Betty folgt ihm nach l.a also
ich dachte mein Leben wäre chaotisch
aber das
hat ja echt noch mal alles
richtig ich weiß nicht vielleicht aber
es wird noch schlimmer weil er Betty für
untreu hält macht fickling schloss sie
zieht planlos in der Gegend umher wohnt
mal bei Freunden mal bei Bekannten in
billigen Hotels immer wieder hat sie
Geld sorgen im Winter 1946 verschlägt es
sie zwischenzeitlich ins südlich
gelegenes San Diego aber auch von da
kehrt sie mit dem Bus nach LA zurück wir
sind jetzt im Januar 1947 betty ist 23
Jahre alt hat noch nie ein regulären
Beruf ausgeübt und ihre
Liebesbeziehungen ja haben noch nicht
wirklich lange gehalten jetzt beginnen
aber ihre letzten Tage und Stunden um
sie zu verstehen schauen wir noch mal
genauer auf die Rückkehr aus San Diego
in der Garnisonsstadt San Diego will
Betty in einem Kino-Saal schlafen weil
sie kein Geld für ein Hotel hat
aber die Kino Kassiererin Dorothy French
hat Mitleid mit ihr und lässt sie bei
ihrer Familie wohnen am 8 januar 1947
schreibt Betty einen Brief an fickling
indem sie mitteilt sie wolle mit einem
gewissen Jack nach Chicago gehen um dort
Model zu werden das ist aber offenbar
auch schon wieder komplett erfunden
vielmehr wird sie nach ein paar Nächten
bei Familie French wieder vor die Tür
gesetzt und will per Anhalter zurück
Richtung l.a mitgenommen wird sie von
einem Autofahrer namens Robert männley
mit ihm übernachtet sie noch eine Nacht
in San Diego er schläft im Bett sie
vollständig angezogen in einem Sessel
denn anscheinend fühlt sie sich nicht so
wohl am nächsten Morgen fährt man Lisi
nach Los Angeles die beiden warten im
Bild nur Hotel in der Innenstadt auf
Bettys Schwester Virginia die sie
angeblich dort abholen will aber auch
das stimmt nicht auch nach Stunden
taucht Virginia nicht auf männlich fährt
ab Betty verlässt das Hotel drei
Menschen gaben später an Betty short an
diesem Abend noch in einer Cocktailbar
in der Innenstadt gesehen zu haben was
danach geschah das ist bis heute
ungeklärt
Werbung heute möchten wir euch
Wolfskinder das Thrillerdebüt von
Autoren Vera Buck vorstellen er Schienen
ist das Buch beim robert-verlag in dem
Buch verschwinden immer wieder Frauen in
einem abgeschiedenen Ort in den Bergen
einer Siedlung fernab von der modernen
Welt hier gelten die Regeln der Natur
rau und erbarmungslos nun möchte die
junge Journalistin Smilla die vor Jahren
ihre Freundin juli in der Gegend
verloren hat der Wahrheit auf die Spur
kommen erst recht als ihr ein
verwahrlostes Mädchen vors Auto läuft
das verblüffende Ähnlichkeit mit Julia
hat und schon bald kommt Smilla einem
schockierenden Geheimnis auf die Spur
das alle vermeintlichen Wahrheiten aus
den Angeln hebt wo lauert das Böse
wirklich mit großer Sprachkraft und
psychologischer Tiefe erzählt Vera Bug
von menschlichen Abgründen erzählt ist
das Buch aus sechs Perspektiven und
bildet durch das Atmosphäre bedrohliche
bergsetting die perfekte abgeschiedene
Kulisse für diesen furiosen Thriller
also große Leseempfehlung für
Wolfskinder von Vera Buck
Werbung Ende
nach dem Fund von Bettys Leiche spielt
Los Angeles verrückt die Schlagzeilen
aller Blätter drehen sich tagelang nur
um die schwarze Dahlie die Frau lässt
sich als Elisabeth short identifizieren
weil es seit dem Vorfall mit dem Alkohol
Fingerabdrücke von ihr gibt die Polizei
sucht verzweifelt nach ihrem Mörder und
sie bekommt viele Hinweise aber keine
heiße Spur da ist zum Beispiel ein
Umschlag der nicht beschrieben sondern
mit ausgeschnittenen zeitungsbuchstaben
geklebt wurde Absender ein Black Dahlia
Avenger darin Bettys Geburtsurkunde ein
Notizbuch und andere persönliche
schreiben diese offenbar echten
Unterlagen bringen genauso wenig eine
Spur wie zahlreiche Geständnisse
für die Ermittler stellt sich dieser
Albtraum nach einer Weile so da
insgesamt hat Betty short den la mit
etwa 50 Männern Sex gehabt und die
müssen überprüft werden und noch einmal
bis zu 50 Männer darunter auch
verurteilte Mörder reichen Geständnisse
ein keines davon erweist sich als seriös
und dann auch noch die Spekulation in
den Zeitungen wird gemutmaßt
Schauspieler Orson Welles könnte mit dem
Fall zu tun haben oder Musiker wo die
guteri oder der Verleger Norman Chandler
die Polizei hat nach dem aussortieren
aller Toten Spuren immer noch 22
Verdächtige auf ihrer Liste aber keiner
von ihnen bringt den Fall voran und so
wird die Geschichte von der schwarzen
Dahlie zu einem codecase und geht in die
Kulturgeschichte ein mehrere Bücher
werden über den Fall von Elisabeth short
bzw Betty geschrieben unter anderem von
Kultautor James elrise auf dessen Roman
beruht wiederum die Verfilmung von
Regisseur Brian der pal aus dem Jahr
2006 aber wir sind noch nicht fertig
denn für eine wirklich verrückte Wendung
sorgt ausgerechnet ein Ermittler des LPD
im Ruhestand der Mann heißt stevogel und
wandte sich 2013 an die Öffentlichkeit
zum Beispiel schrieb die Zeitung BZ
damals nach 66 Jahren Mordfall schwarze
Dahlie gelöst und tatsächlich war die
Geschichte die Hotel erzählte verdammt
gut und fasziniert die Frau du glaubt
dass sein eigener Vater der Mörder von
Elisabeth short gewesen sein könnte
er hieß George und war am Los Angeles
der 1940er Jahre Arzt es ist ein ganz
interessanter Hinweis denn wenn wir uns
an den Anfang erinnern wurde davon
fürchterlich präzisen Schnitten
gesprochen mit denen Betty zerteilt
wurde gut
aber es kommt ja noch besser ist die
Vogel fand im Nachlass des Vaters eine
Kiste mit Fotos und darunter waren
Schnappschüsse von Elizabeth short
außerdem fanden sich kunstfotos der
Surrealisten men-ray der war ein Freund
der Familie Hodel und er war bekannt für
seine skurrilen inszenierten Fotografien
einige von ihnen wirken die Bilder aus
einer Geschichte wie der schwarzen
Dahlie das mit den Bildern von men Ray
mag er vielleicht auch Zufall als ein
aber ein Blick zurück ergab noch mehr
Spannung
1947 war George Hodel doch tatsächlich
auf der Verdächtigen Liste der Polizei
zum Zeitpunkt des Mordes war er alleine
zu Hause und seine Frau verreist doch
bevor George Hodel verhört wurde verließ
der Arzt seine Familie und wanderte nach
Asien aus dort starb er 1991 Jahr
später fand sein Sohns die faudel das
Mietshaus in LA wieder in dem die
Familie damals gewohnt hatte mit
Kollegen vom LAPD und einem
Leichenspürhund gegen Hodel in den
Keller des Gebäudes Labrador Buster
schlug an an vier Stellen des Kellers
muss eine Leiche gelegen haben die
Beamten haben dann Bodenproben genommen
so stand es damals also 2013 weltweit in
den Zeitungen aber so viel versprechen
diese Spuren auch klangen sie führten
wieder ins Nichts stelle ich mir aber
auch schwierig vor wenn dein
Hauptverdächtiger zu dem Zeitpunkt dann
schon tot ist
aber gut es bleibt wohl ein tragischer
Fall und für immer ein Cold Case aber
genau das ist es ja auch was diese
Geschichte so faszinierend macht und
irgendwie hat Elisabeth Short ist ja
dann auch geschafft ihren Traum zu
verwirklichen sie wollte in Hollywood
berühmt werden und leider hat sie das
dann auch geschafft also nach ihrem Tod
die schwarze Dahlie haben wir unter
anderem mit dem gleichnamigen Buch von
James el Roy erzählt mit einer Chronik
des Santa Barbara independent sowie der
Los Angeles Times
Schnitt und Aufnahme Toni Haier das
Skript hat uns Stefan Nettebad
geschrieben Postproduktion durch die
Wake Word Studios München das war's für
heute danke fürs zuhören und bis morgen
eure Toni und euer